Thank you Squarespace for sponsoring this
video.
Todo is one of the strongest smartest and
most controversial characters in Jujutsu Kaisen.
He has a ridiculously fast paced character
arc and goes from brutal borderline berserker
to charming gentle giant in under 3 episodes.
He has a self proclaimed IQ of 530.000; judges
people based on their type of woman; manages
to creep Itadori out, which is a real feat;
And on top of all that, with Boogie Woogie,
he one of the most fascinating powers in the
story. - In this video you will learn everything
there is to know about Todo. How strong he
is. How smart he is. That his awesome voice
actor is actually German; - I know! The hell?!
- And of course the hidden genius behind his
philosophy and design as a character, that
make him one of the most loved characters
by fans and one of the most disliked characters
in the story. This is the character analysis
of Aoi Todo. -
Okay, let's get the elephant out of the room,
as in let's talk about the elephant. Remember
how these guys are all supposed to be high
schoolers? Well, Todo looks like a 28 year
old philosophy student f***d a truck-load
of protein powder. ... now that I think about
it, that actually sums up his personality
pretty perfectly as well. Huh.
In terms of power, Akutami introduces Todo
as a realistic measuring stick for Itadori
and co. Someone who is a whole level or two
above them all, but more in reach than the
walking and talking calamity that is Satoru
Gojo. In fact, Todo is undoubtedly one of
the, if not THE strongest among the current
students. And yes, Fushiguro doing a kamikaze
attack does not count. Despite being only
a second year student, Todo is already a full-fledged
first grade sorcerer. Just so you have some
comparison, that is the same grade as Nanami
or Yaga, who is a school director. As if this
wasn't enough however, most of the time, Todo
doesn't even use his extraordinary cursed
ability, but simply raw physical ability.
Not only does he have a ridiculous amount
of brute strength, but is also surprisingly
agile. - When things turn dark however, which
pretty much only means special grade kind
of bad, Todo unpacks his innate jujutsu ability:
The Boogie Woogie, that allows him to switch
the positions of anything with cursed energy
within his range with a clap of his hands.
He can change himself out with the location
of another person, or switch two different
parties other than himself as well. -
Now, is this technique powerful? Obviously.
But I want you to appreciate for a moment,
what an unusual match-up this power is for
a hulk-like guy like Todo. Because once again,
here, as you know from my other videos, Akutami
loves playing with expectations. Usually,
the trope of the beefcake character in Anime
is kind of predictable. Either he is a lot
weaker and more stupid than all the weak looking
people around him, or he gets a boring power,
like making his body harder than it already
is... or a big weapon or something...basically
that's the guy who always goes down first.
The idea being that we as the audience go:
Oh he looks strong, how will our skinny hero
beat him. And then we are surprised how powerful
the small guy actually is. The trope was basically
dead after David vs Goliath. But it keeps
coming back for some reason.
Anyways, Todo flips that trop on its head
in the sense that he looks incredibly strong,
and he is incredibly strong. And not only
that he also has an ability that requires
him to basically play 4D chess with his opponent
all the time, trying to figure out if, what,
when and where he is gonna switch. A buff
dude, who is actually buff and has an elegant
ability that requires brains. Hey Anime industry,
Was it really so hard to come up with a character
like this?
Because on top of his power, oh boy, Todo
is a pretty sharp cookie. Not sure if he's
530.000 IQ points sharp, as he likes to claim,
but he's definitely no dummy either. So let's
talk about Todo's big brain, and what exactly
is going on in there, so that we can get two
as different sounding exclamations from him
as this - nature, type - So, let's talk about
Todo's personality.
- But first Ad Break -
Real quick, I wanna say thank you to square
space, who is the sponsor of this video, thank
you square space. I have made creative content
on YouTube for over 2 years now and can code...I
COULD code, and still, designing my own website
has always been a super daunting task for
me. Coming up with all the functionalities
I want it to have, creating a functioning
design from scratch, coding to bring it all
to live. Web design is just too hard. The
reason I like Squarespace is that it lets
you build your own personal website super
easily. They have a ton of wonderfully designed
web design templates that you can customize
to create your very own professional looking
website with no prior knowledge whatsoever,
so you can host your very own content on the
good old internet. Head over to [Squarespace.com](http://squarespace.com/)
to try it out, and once you’re ready to
launch, us my link in the description below
to get 10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain.
Out of all the things to love about Todo,
my favorite thing is probably the way he gets
introduced into the story. Basically Akutami
hits us with the worst part of his personality
to paint this picture of a blood-hungry idiot,
who judges people based on their taste of
women...which he does, but as you will see,
surprisingly there is lot more behind this.
Anyways, so after basically beating Megumi
into a pulp for having a decent view of women,
- We get a pretty rapid turnaround for his
character. First we see him going against
the plan to assassinate Yuji, basically having
as little respect for his classmates and teachers
as for Megumi. Still no reason to like him,
but at least we get, that this man acts on
his own principals and isn't just a dick for
the sake of it. And the we of course get his
interaction with Itadori. And oh boy, is it
no surprise that these two click. - After
making up a fake flashback in his head, that
has more plot development than most regular
anime do, Todo suddenly sees Itadori as his
best friend and from then on mentors Yuji
and brings him to a completely different level
in a number of minutes, suddenly turning him
into an absolute fan favorite. Oh and can
we talk about the fact, that Todo got rejected
in his own fantasy AND chose Itadori over
his love. What a true bro.
Now we don't really know if theses fake memories
have something to do with Yui or wether they
simply are part of quirky personality, as
I personally like to think. After all, in
his fight with Hanami, Todo has an entire
imaginary tactical meeting with his favorite
pop idol in the blink of second. - So I think
that crafting a made up back story for one
few people he can respect in the world, next
to anyone who is stronger than him, in other
words special grades like Gojo, is very much
in character for Todo. And I think this proves
how smart a cookie he actually is. After all
you will find it hard to describe this creative
ability together with the ridiculously fast
analytical information processing as anything
but intelligent. On top of all this Todo is
an extremely smart and dexterous fighter when
he has to, unpacking his cursed technique
to its fullest against Hanami, an enemy he
cannot beat with power alone.
However, this sort of intelligence, while
without any doubt impressive, pales in comparison
to the part of Todo's character that I find
truly impressive. His abs. I'm just kidding,
the truly impressive part about Todo is his
philosophy and approach to the central moral
question of the story, that make him one of
the most wise characters in the story. -
Todo's answer to 'what makes a good life worth
living?' is basically existentialism. While
jus like Nanami or Mahito, he understands
that life doesn't have meaning in itself and
that very much in the Buddhist way of thinking,
everything is fleeting, Todo believes that
people are capable of making their own purpose
and find a reason to love and embrace life.
His understanding of the natural world even
gives him a better understanding of cursed
energy. And other than Mahito, who as I explained
in my last video, wants to fully embrace his
nature, Todo gives Yuji agency, by telling
him to accept being part of nature, while
still having his own will and swallowing his
anger. Todo is someone who fights against
the natural order of things, for the sake
of the love he feels for other people. He
even literally fights Hanami, who is an embodiment
of nature. In fact, as ironic as it might
seem, - believe me I know - love is actually
the big theme behind Todo's character. So
much so, that Akutami even draws his cursed
energy as taking the form of little hearts.
Love in general is a very prominent theme
in Jujutsu Kaisen, that often is contrasted
with
the curses. -Junpei-
What appears as comical and over the top on
the outside, when Todo suddenly treats Yuji
as if they had known each other since birth,
is actually Todo embracing his friendship
and brotherly love for Yuji as one of the
driving factors in his life. Just as his love
for Takada. Even though, they aren't even
real, to Todo they are and they give him meaning
and happiness. Not by accident, but by choice.
And even his seemingly macho-like habit of
judging people based on their type of partner,
gets twisted on his head, when we learn that
he isn't just a superficial duche, but actually
inherited this quirk as well as his philosophy
from the mysterious motorbike woman we meet.
What Todo actually does by asking the question,
is figuring out whether or not people can
state their true feeling and know what they
love. It's not that everyone needs to love
Jennifer Lawrence, it's that Yuji has no issues
saying what he loves, while Megumi does. Though
I think you agree, that that doesn't mean
you have to punch him into the ground. The
fact that not everyone is able to state what
they love or even know what they love is something
todo has to learn to understand. His basic
need as a character.
As a result Todo is written as a twist on
the unwind trope that strong guys are always
stupid and for some reason weak, making him
one of the strongest and wisest characters
in the story, while still being as bat shit
crazy as all of them really are. He is one
of the central guides to Itadori's growth
and without any doubt part of the relationships
that Yuji will someday have to discover as
his true source of meaning and happiness in
life. In short, pretty much as most characters
in Jujutsu Kaisen, Aoi Todo might as well
be the main character. Like Maki or Fushiguro,
he's pretty much peak Shounen protagonist
material. And that's what makes him such a
lovable character.
What better way to continue, than talk about
Todo's major enemy in the story, both physically
and philosophically. -
Watch my analysis of Hanami, an absolutely
fascinating character, by clicking right here.
Or check out my other Jujutsu Kaisen character
analysis here. Thanks for watching. Peace.